you might remember that throughout his
entire presidential campaign Donald
Trump talked endlessly about how he
would be doing major infrastructure
spending and you might also remember
that after that really horrible Amtrak
train crash a train derailment late in
2017 Trump tweeted that the crash was
evidence of the acute need for
infrastructure spending you might
remember Trump sent the tweet that quote
the train accident just occurred in
Dupont Washington shows more than ever
why are soon to be submitted
infrastructure plan must be approved
quickly seven trillion dollars spent in
the Middle East while our roads bridges
tunnels railways and more crumble not
for long
now the problem with that tweet as I
pointed out a couple weeks ago when we
did the story was that the crash
actually didn't relate to infrastructure
spending that Trump planned to do it was
a new train on recently refurbished
tracks but the big picture is still
something that was part of Trump's plan
right big infrastructure spending and he
even said Amtrak related infrastructure
spending just before the end of 2017
Donald Trump decided to stop a 13
billion dollar spending plan which would
have rebuilt an amtrak passageway from
New York to New Jersey wait a second
Trump says he wants to do infrastructure
spending there is an Amtrak train
infrastructure I'm sorry there's an
Amtrak train crash Trump then says the
crash further points to the need to do
infrastructure spending there's a plan
to do that spending which would improve
Amtrak and Trump cancels the plan what
what is going on here there is one word
which might be the key in understanding
what happened here that word is Obama
this was an Obama agreement with the
governors of New York and New Jersey but
it has Obama's name on it so it's a
no-go for Trump there's no real agenda
here for Trump other than dismantle
everything Obama did right if it was
Obama's idea Trump wants it gone period
even if it sounds like the same thing
that Trump campaigned on doing during
his presidential campaign
could this work to get Trump to support
things that we want right hey Donny boy
Obama hates single-payer health care
really maybe Trump wants single-payer
all of a sudden by the way this is also
a good opportunity to talk about the
Trump infrastructure spending plans as
the crony capitalist handouts that they
are last a couple weeks ago when we did
the story about the Amtrak crash and I
talked about just the hypocrisy and and
delusions of Donald Trump on
infrastructure I forgot to mention that
even though Trump says he wants to do
infrastructure spending the way he wants
to do it would be a major hand out to
his buddies and a total swamp job a
swamp filling crony capitalist cherry on
top of the Trump agenda for lack of a
better term so take this all together
right an irrational and unhinged desire
to undo everything Obama did combined
with a desire to put in place more
profits for his friends in any place
that he can it's absolute in total chaos
and this is part of the reason that
government is not efficient as efficient
as it could be you have the people on
the right who said government is just
fundamentally inefficient and it should
do a little as possible we have this
endless cycle where as soon as one
administration starts moving forward in
one area the next administration cancels
it and you end up spending millions or
even billions of dollars starting for
preparing for and requisitioning
supplies or staff for projects that then
get cancelled for political reasons by
the next administration this is part of
the inefficiency of government that the
right likes to point to yeah an Obama
did push for infrastructure spending
right especially when it came to the
stimulus package yep but Donald Trump
could have gone one step beyond that
right and maybe if that was his first
action as president trying to push for
that people would respond favorably and
his approval numbers could be north of
50 percent by now of course of course
and instead it's been just trying to
undo anything that President Obama
proposed or put in motion or did
combined with basically stepping aside
from his broad policy proposals that he
campaigned on many of them just to diss
the wall with Mexico
what happened to the wall with Mexico is
anyone even thinking about the wall with
Mexico at this point it's just
abundantly clear that it was all the
bamboozling of his base and it goes back
to what goes back to how politics are
funded it goes back to campaign finance
citizens united and lobbyists and crony
capitalism all roads on any issue we
talk about all train tracks if that's
what you want to call them it all leads
back to those same issues and we'll be
talking about those issues big-time in
2018 today's program is sponsored in
part by zip recruiter if you are hiring
do you know where to post your job to
find the best candidates what if hiring
could be easier more streamlined less
time-consuming so that even if you're at
a busy time in your business which you
probably are if you're looking to hire
you can still be smart about the way
that you higher quality hires are
arguably the most important factor in
keeping your business moving forward but
it can take a lot of time to find the
right candidate for the job with zip
recruiter you can post your job to over
100 of the internet's leading job boards
with a single click
zip recruiter will use its smart
matching technology to notify qualified
candidates about your job within minutes
of posting and you'll get the best
possible matches this is why zip
recruiter is different unlike other
hiring sites zip recruiter doesn't
depend on the candidates finding you it
will find the right candidates for your
position which is why 80% of employers
who post on zip recruiter get at least
one quality candidate within just one
day no juggling emails or calls to your
office you can use the zip recruiter
dashboard to screen rate and hire the
right person and right now david pakman
show viewers and listeners can post jobs
on zip recruiter for free that's right
free go to zip recruiter comm slash PA
que ma n that's zip recruiter dot-com
slash Pakman one more time try it free
zip recruiter dot-com slash PA que ma n